en angoulême en el sudoeste de francia a
los propietarios de los negocios dicen
que el toque de queda a partir de las
seis de la tarde significará una pérdida
de ingresos significativa
desde las 7 hasta las 8 y media es
cuando hacemos más dinero se representa
en términos de ingresos por ventas pues
unos mil euros aproximadamente muchos
propietarios están explorando maneras de
compensar este cierre anticipado a abrir
durante la hora del almuerzo abrir los
días en los que normalmente serían sus
días de descanso u ofrecer servicios a
domicilio pero como explican estos
floristas hay todavía bastantes
preguntas estamos esperando ver cómo
podemos organizar entregas no sé si
seremos capaces de hacer entregas a
domicilio un poco más tarde habrá
excepciones para la gente que trabaja
haciendo entregas a domicilio no lo
sabemos no está demasiado claro algunos
sin embargo están tratando de entender
la situación y dicen que la medida era
necesaria yo dirijo una tienda así que
vamos a tener que cerrar más pronto nos
estamos adaptando no creo que sea una
mala medida y realmente debería
extenderse porque el virus está en todas
partes
funes el primer ministro jan castex dijo
que el país no había visto un aumento de
los casos después de las festividades de
fin de año pero aún así impuso
restricciones más severas el toque de
queda a las 6 de la tarde se prolongará
por al menos 15 días